MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO SAY ON THAT.
BUT FIRST, WELCOME TO THE END OF
DAY TEN.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
THE NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT SHUT DOWN
OF A VIRUS THAT ARRIVED VIA
CHINA.
WE HAVE A LOT OF NEW INFORMATION
AT THIS HOUR, THE NUMBER OF
CORONAVIRUS INFECTIONS IN THE
U.S. STANDS AT 83,000.
THAT IS AN INCREASE OF ABOUT
20,000 FROM YESTERDAY, WE ARE
DOING A LOT MORE TESTING.
THE DAY BEFORE THAT JUMPED BY
11,000.
THE NUMBER OF THOSE RECOVERED IS
18624, AND THE NUMBERS OF DEAD
IS AT LEAST 1201, AN INCREASE OF
314 FROM THE PREVIOUS 24-HOUR
PERIOD.
THE DAY BEFORE THAT, THEY ROSE
BY 212.
WE ARE NOT AT PEAK OF AT LEAST
NOT YET AND CERTAINLY NOT IN THE
COVID HOT SPOTS.
NEW YORK, IT REMAINS THE
EPICENTER OF THIS VIRUS.
55% OF ALL NEW INFECTIONS, 1/3
OF ALL DEATHS OCCURRING THERE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO OFFERED SOME GOOD
NEWS ON THE ISSUE THAT PEOPLE
WERE UNDERSTANDABLY FREAKING OUT
ABOUT JUST A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
THAT IS THE QUESTION OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF GOWNS AND MASKS.
TO SPEAK OF EQUIPMENT AND PPE IS
ONGOING ISSUE, WE DO HAVE ENOUGH
PPE FOR THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE.
THE NEW YORK CITY HOSPITAL
SYSTEM CONFIRMED THAT.
SO, WE HAVE ENOUGH IN STOCK NOW
FOR THE IMMEDIATE NEED.
>> Laura: HE OFFERED ANOTHER
STARK WARNING ON ICU BEDS AND
VENTILATOR NEEDS.
>> VENTILATORS, VENTILATORS,
VENTILATORS.
WE ARE STILL SHOPPING FOR
VENTILATORS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, WE NEED MORE.
THE HOSPITALS HAVE 53,000 BED
CAPACITY, WE ARE TRYING TO GET
140,000 BETWEEN HOSPITALS AND
OVERFLOW FACILITIES.
WE ARE ALSO SCOUTING DORMS,
HOTELS FOR EMERGENCY BEDS.
>> Laura: DAYS AGO, THE ANGLE
HAD STARTED TO CRUNCH THE REAL
NUMBERS FOR BOTH ITALY’S COVID
EXPERIENCE AND CHINA.
THE DIRE WARNINGS THAT HUNDREDS
OF CITIZENS OF VENTILATORS WERE
GOING TO BE NEEDED, AND
POTENTIALLY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS COULD’VE
DIED.
NEITHER OF WHICH MATCH THE NEW
DATA THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT,
THESE PROJECTIONS WERE BASED ON
A MODEL DONE BY THE TEAM AT
IMPERIAL COLLEGE IN LONDON.
TODAY, THIS IS WHAT OUR INSTINCT
WAS.
THE LEAD RESEARCHER DID AN
ABOUT-FACE, TERRIFYING
PROJECTIONS.
THE VERY PROJECTIONS THAT DROVE.
>> THERE WOULD BE 500,000 DEATHS
IN THE U.K., 2.2 MILLION DEATHS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY HAVE ADJUSTED THAT NUMBER
IN THE U.K. TO 20,000, THE
PREDICTIONS OF THE MODELS DON’T
MATCH THE REALITY ON THE GROUND
IN EITHER CHINA, SOUTH KOREA, OR
ITALY.
WHEN PEOPLE START TALKING ABOUT
20% OF THE POPULATION GETTING
INFECTED, IT IS VERY SCARY.
BUT WE DON’T HAVE DATA THAT
MATCHES THAT BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCE.
>> Laura: THAT DATA OF ACTUAL
COVID HOSPITALIZATIONS AND ICU
NEEDS AND FORMS TO QUESTIONS OF
HOW MANY VENTILATORS WILL BE
NEEDED, AND THE NIGHTMARE
SCENARIO THAT WOULD HAVE TO
RATION CARE.
>> RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN SEE THESE
CASES ARE CONCENTRATED IN HIGHLY
URBAN AREAS.
THERE ARE OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT HAVE LOTS OF
VENTILATORS, AND OTHER PARTS OF
NEW YORK STATE THAT DON’T HAVE
ANY INFECTIONS RIGHT NOW.
SO WE CAN BE CREATIVE, WE CAN
MEET THE NEED BY BEING
RESPONSIVE.
BUT THERE IS NO MODEL RIGHT NOW,
NO REALITY ON THE GROUND WHERE
WE CAN SEE THAT 60-70% OF
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO GET
INFECTED IN THE NEXT 8-12 WEEKS.
>> IT APPEARS THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO’S DIRE
PRODUCTIONS ARE BASED ON THAT
ORIGINAL FAULTY MODEL THAT
DIDN’T INCLUDE THE CLINICAL
REPORTING BY THE CHINESE AND
ITALIAN HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS.
NOW, VIEWERS OF THE SHOW, YOU
ARE ALREADY AWARE OF THE FAULTY
MODELING DONE ON COVID BECAUSE I
ASKED DR. FAUCI ABOUT THIS ON
TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> IF THE NUMBERS ARE NOT RIGHT,
IT AFFECTS THE DECISION-MAKING
ABOUT WHEN THE COUNTRY CAN
GRADUALLY GET BACK TO BUSINESS.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> Laura: ON BOTH THE ISSUE OF
PROMISING THERAPIES LIKE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, THE ANALYSIS
USED IN THESE PRODUCTIONS,
PRODUCTIONS, THE INGRAHAM ANGLE
HAS BEEN DAYS IF NOT WEEKS AHEAD
OF SOME OF THE MAJOR NEWS
NETWORKS.
WHY IS THAT?
HOW IS THAT?
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO ASSEMBLE
MY OWN TEAM OF MEDICAL ADVISORS,
AND YOU ALL KNOW WHO YOU ARE OUT
THERE.
THEY WERE RAISING ALL THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS, STUFF THAT I WOULD
NOT KNOW ABOUT BUT THEY DO.
THEY ACTUALLY ARE PEOPLE WHO
TREAT COVID PATIENTS, DAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
MANY OF THESE SO-CALLED EXPERTS,
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY,
HAVE FAILED US IN THE PAST ON
REALLY KEY ISSUES.
THINK ABOUT IRAQ, THINK ABOUT
TRADE WITH CHINA, THINK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF BORDER
ENFORCEMENT.
THE INTERNET BUBBLE, THE HOUSING
BUBBLE.
AND NOW, THE CDC’S COVID TESTING
TESTING.
TIME WILL TELL JUST HOW
ACCURATE, OR INACCURATE, THE
EXPERTS WERE IN THIS CRISIS.
WAS A TOTAL SHUTDOWN THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO?
OR SHOULD WE HAVE TAKEN A MORE
MODIFIED APPROACH, AKIN TO WHAT
SWEDEN IS DOING?
SHOULD WE BE WAITING FOR THE
HERD IMMUNITY TO DEVELOP OR
FORCE EVERYONE TO ISOLATE AND
HOPE THE SECOND WAVE OF
INFECTION NEVER COMES?
IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE LUCKY TO
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO TRUSTS, BUT
THEN VERIFIES WHAT THE EXPERTS
HAVE BEEN SAYING.
AND BALANCES THAT WITH THE
OVERALL NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND ECONOMY.
HE ANNOUNCED TODAY HE WILL BE
RELEASING NEW GUIDELINES FOR THE
GOVERNORS, GRADUAL, RELAXING OF
THE SHUTDOWN IN AREAS THAT HAVE
MANAGED TO ESCAPE THE WORST OF
THE VIRUS.
>> WE DO HAVE 19 OUT OF 50
STATES TO BE REMINDED, THEY HAD
EARLY CASES BUT HAVE LOW LEVEL
OF CASES AT THIS POINT.
THAT IS ALMOST 40% OF THE
COUNTRY WITH EXTRAORDINARILY LOW
NUMBERS, AND THEY ARE TESTING,
THESE 19 STATES ARE STILL DOING
ACTIVE CONTAINMENT.
THEY ARE AT 200 CASES, JUST THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
MEASURING THEM FOR THE LAST 3-4
WEEKS.
>> Laura: EVEN THEN, IF THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE LIFTED IT
DOESN’T MEAN THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
GO ABOUT THEIR MERRY WAY LIKE
BEFORE THE VIRUS.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT I
THINK IS GOING TO ADVISE.
THEY SHOULD NOT STILL LET THEIR
GUARDS DOWN.
>> I WANT BOTH GUIDELINES TO GO
EVEN WHEN WE ARE OPEN AND FULLY
OPERATION, AND FRANKLY MUCH OF T
GUIDELINES LIKE SHAKING
HANDS MAYBE PEOPLE AREN’T GOING
TO BE SHAKING HANDS ANYMORE.
AS SOON AS WE OPEN, THAT DOESN’T
MEAN YOU’RE GOING TO STOP.
YOU WILL STILL TRY AND DISTANCE
YOURSELF, MAYBE NOT TO THE SAME
EXTENT BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO LEAD
A LIFE.
BUT I THINK THE TIME IS COMING.
>> Laura: COMMON SENSE, WHEN
WILL THAT REIGN SUPREME?
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE VIRUS OR
NO VIRUS, PEOPLE DON’T HAVE A
WAY TO MAKE A LIVING ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS IF THINGS
COLLAPSE, BUSINESSES GO OUT,
BANKS GO UNDER, RESTAURANTS GO
UNDER, JOBS NEVER RETURN,
CERTAIN TYPES OF JOBS DON’T MAKE
IT.
IF THE LONG-TERM TO AMERICA IS
THIS INSIDIOUS VIRUS, THOSE ARE